Hey, everyone.
We are looking at our chapter three and we're going to be ...
taking a look at some work problems,
which are questions and how I would answer these questions.
These align with what we see in the chapter along with ...
those learning objectives.
Let's go ahead and dive into it.
Our first question says Alex gives up a 75 concert ticket to ...
study for an exam and instead watches free lectures online.
So the studying is going to be watching the free lectures ...
online, giving up the 75 concert ticket.
What is the opportunity cost of studying?
Remember, opportunity cost is the ...
highest valued, foregone alternative.
And in this case, we are doing studying as ...
opposed to going to a concert.
So the concert is the next best alternative.
So the value of that concert ticket would be our answer.
That is our opportunity cost of studying that $75 concert ticket.
All right, a bakery is deciding whether ...
to open on Sundays.
Which of the following should be considered relevant costs?
Relevant costs are things that are going to change as your ...
output changes, not fixed cost,
which don't matter once they've already been incurred.
So rent on the building is going to be a fixed cost.
Advertising spent last year, that's an irrelevant cost.
Does it matter about current production?
Depreciation on the oven also gets thrown into your fixed cost.
So this means extra wages paid by paid to Sunday ...
workers are going to be relevant costs because those ...
are costs that we're going to continue to incur as we open ...
on Sunday and as we produce more.
So that's why B is our answer.
Our next question.  A factory pays 5,000 per month in rent.
So that 5,000 in rent is going to be a fixed cost,
$4 per unit produced in material.
So $4 per unit.
Let's make that a little dollar sign there.
That is going to be a variable cost.
It changes, it increases as we.
If output increases from 1000 to 1500 units,
so we have 500 units increased there,
how much does variable cost increase?
So in this case, we have a $4 per unit.
Now, that's actually an average ...
variable cost, which isn't a part of this ...
chapter is what we cover in our next chapter.
But if we take the average variable cost,
which is simply our variable cost divided by our quantity,
then we have four equals variable cost over 500.
We do a little cross multiplication there and we ...
get variable cost equal $2,000,
which is why B is our answer.
Let's move on. A firm earns 300,000 in ...
revenue. Okay?
So total revenue tr equals 300,000 incurs 1800.
Excuse me, 180,000 in accounting cost.
So our accounting costs, which are going to be our ...
explicit costs, These are costs that incur cash payment.
That equals $1800, 1,800,
$180,000 and gives up 50,000 in foregone salary.
Now that's an implicit cost.
So let's write out implicit cost here.
So that's 50,000.
Okay, what is the economic profit?
Economic profit is your total revenue minus your total 300,000.
Minus 180,000.
Minus 50,000.
Okay, so 300,000 minus 180,000 is 120,000.
120,000 minus 50,000 gives us C 70,000.
Now, economic profit,
again, accounts for your explicit and ...
your implicit cost, whereas accounting profit ...
only accounts for your explicit cost.
So that's why 70,000 is is going to be our answer.
If we were looking for accounting profit,
then we just would have stopped with A as our answer.
All right, let's move on to our next question.
A firm considers whether to shut down a product line but ...
insist on keeping it running because they've already ...
invested 1 million in equipment.
What fallacy are they committing?
And that's easy.
That's the fixed cost fallacy.
We've already incurred the $1 million.
It doesn't mention the fact that we're going to get this ...
back in any way, shape or form.
So we are assuming that is a sunk cost.
All right, that's the sunk cost fallacy,
also known as the fixed cost policy.
Once that investment has already incurred and you ...
can't get any of it back, then it is a sunk cost.
It is irrelevant for future decision making,
and we should not be worrying about whether or ...
not to include that $1 million in our decisions.
All right, let's move to our last question ...
here for chapter three.
A company hires a contractor for $60 an hour.  Okay.
But ignores the fact that in house,
staff could do the same job for $40 an hour.
What cost are they overlooking?
Okay, so A will not work.
A says the sunk cost of previous training.
We're not thinking about that.
We're thinking about what we could actually use,
the PC people that we've already trained for.
So sunk cost doesn't matter in this case,
the explicit cost of the contractor.
I think they're actually very much considering the explicit ...
cost of the contractor here because we have a $60 per hour mention.
The opportunity cost of using internal staff.
Yeah, that's what we're looking for ...
as our answer here.
We have $40 an hour versus $60 an hour in this case.
What we're looking at is a big time loss.
For the company because they could be saving $20 per ...
hour by using staff that they already have.
So the opportunity cost is the next highest valued.
Next, excuse me,
the highest valued foregone alternative.
Well, in this case,
the highest value forgotten alternative is the $40 per ...
hour, which is actually cheaper,
which is what we should be using.
So that's the cost that they are overlooking,
the opportunity cost of actually using that internal ...
staff and this firm.
If they're thinking about equating their marginal ...
revenue to their marginal cost,
then they probably do want to use that internal staff ...
because it's probably going to get them more in line with ...
profit maximizing opportunities than using a ...
contractor for $60 an hour.
All right, that is it for chapter three.
Hope you have enjoyed it.